hello and welcome to
the uh games for after dark podcast
that was the uh running start to the
podcast because i was taking my
headphones off so yeah i'm sorry i'm
sorry for bringing up like i was like
she's right i should take the headphones
off but when i took the headphones off i
could no longer hear the
the actual starting theme so i just
looked up and we were on the screen and
i was like oh
and this is episode 156 of the gamespot
after dog podcast i am your host
tomorrow saying joined by jean-luc
saipki hi hello how are you doing sean
luke i'm okay what are you drinking i'm
drinking some uh angry orchard uh peach
mango hard cider how is it
uh it's pretty good i like i like a good
like fruit combo uh like i have a lot of
juice and i'll usually try and get like
a like a mango lemonade or
something like that you know speaking of
fruit combos jake is here as well
what does that even mean
there are definitely some
interpretations hi i'm drinking uh
anchor steam
classic disappear
what kind of beer tell me more what kind
of view it's a steam beer so anchor
steam i believe uses a steaming process
to make their beer that's all i know i
think i've been to the brewery and i
think yeah because of san francisco
right
i have been to that brewery and they did
use them speaking of steaming processes
lucy is here hi how are you doing lucy
was you're not a half fruit what'd you
say i don't remember what it was
uh fruit blend i don't know i'm i'm very
well i'm drinking um because i'm a basic
[ __ ] a uh
natural lime white claw nothing natural
about it no and i just scarfed a
snickers bar with the ferocity of
someone's snickers what did you find the
snickers
vending machine
oh my god is it actual snickers yeah
mate oh
it's a whole new world um with the
ferocity of someone who hasn't eaten in
three days just because
i just walked from the bus up to the
office and that really took it out of me
so
i wish i was kidding
i'm drinking a canada dry ginger ale um
first time you've had a candidate the
first time i've had a canada dryer and
let me tell you
it's decent it's good usually ginger
ales in the united states of america oh
i mean
says it in the name though not good
canada oh yes canada driving yeah
let's go canada i'm all on board for
canada they got something i guess they
got going for them
uh
let's kick off with
what we've been playing as always as
always also i haven't filled my section
out neither of lucy well cause we've
been playing the same game and we don't
know if we're allowed to talk about it i
checked we're not allowed to talk about
it are you joking yeah so there's a
[ __ ] streaming embargo there's no
streaming embargo people are streaming
it they are streaming the demo
i checked and they were like nobody
should be talking about the game there's
only a review burger so someone we know
who has been talking about the game
should not be talking about the game
there were a few people i saw posting
about it uh jean-luc hi hello
uh we can't actually say what the game
is yeah i was going to say
that is the equivalent oh the demo is
out so the thing the game that people
are talking about is cult of the lamb
oh
okay okay so um that otherwise that
would have been the equivalent of like
just [ __ ] tweeting out an unhappy
face and then waiting for everyone to go
are you okay hon yeah so we've been
playing cult of the lamb
what do you think of it that is all i
will say that is classified information
[Music]
that you can have yes okay cool oh [ __ ]
yeah do you remember when ubisoft are
like you can't talk about assassin's
creed valhalla but you can explain the
emotions the emotions that you felt oh
god
yeah that was one that was genuinely a
preview embargo that they had so what
we're talking people tweeting out i am
very
happy right now the clouds in this game
make me feel pensive
ubisoft has tried some very experimental
embargoes over the years yeah yeah yeah
very few of them have worked yeah they
sure have
um so jean-luc what you've been up to
uh
let's see what did what did i put on
that list you put bam breakfast bearing
breakfast
obsessed with bear and breakfast i think
i played
is well not the best character uh who
will the bird the
pigeon the 50-eyed pigeon oh he's good
um i like
i like julia the little goat
she's really cute
i like her a lot i also like hank a lot
because hank's just like a big dumb
idiot and
but he's like really sweet and i love
him he's the bear yeah and the bear and
breakfast the titular bath the titular
bear
uh yeah i think i put like 15 hours into
that game wow already damn yeah or that
sounded way more judgmental than i meant
already no i mean
there's nothing else to do don't you
have a life jesus i mean i probably
should have been doing more like
housework but then georgia were just
like what if we sit down and just play
bear and breakfast all day yeah so we
just like hooked it up to the tv and
then we're like playing together um
georgia kelly and i have a group chat
well we typically just talk about the
sims and um
there was cali said that yesterday
um
they were stuck in the oh wait uh the
iron nails stuff
oh yes the iron nail shortage yeah
the insulation hits us all
cali just messaged to say i'm stuck in
berm breakfast because there's an issue
with the iron nails economy
so there is a like
certain
uh one of the materials the iron nails
are like needed for um
i think like if you want to make some of
the higher tier wardrobes and beds
and so you're like it's a pretty
important resource you know if you want
to like upgrade those those beds to like
level three plus
and you could only ever get it in
i think like in the when the game
happened you would pretty much only ever
find it in like broken down beds or like
couches which would always be in like
the newer places that you would have to
clean up
but
in the like respondable areas it would
never spawn or like the spawn rate would
be crazy low so
basically uh you just kind of hit a
point in that game where you're like i
can't
i can't build the stuff i need and uh
yeah they were like we're aware of the
shortage they did issue a patch and it
does work now so i have my iron nails
but how would that affect the economy of
iron nails if they added more do you
think that would devalue iron nails oh
my god
you know what they're just printing more
money that's a good point uh
economy's out of balance i do have a
question though what's the what's the
ratio i guess of
crafting and building as opposed to
exploring and talking to people and
stuff because i'm curious about this
game every time i see people walking
around talking to people but then the
second i see people building things i
don't it's mostly that it's mostly that
because the
the walking around is just walking
around to pick up craftable materials
okay and craft more stuff so you have to
be into that aspect of it and i will say
there's some parts of it where it kind
of gets a little monotonous
but there's a story right there is a
story yeah there's a story and there's
dialogue and the dialogue is it's really
funny it's well written it's really
charming um all the characters are
really cute and great and like that
aspect is is definitely there but like
the the core of it is like building
these ins and like you know upgrading
the materials and like getting new
new stuff they have elements like oh
there's a like a cooking mini game and i
was like really excited about it because
i love cooking mini games in pretty much
any game
it's
kind of more annoying than i want it to
be where it's it's a
it's like this card system where like
you get a recipe and the recipe you have
to you lost me a card system it's i
don't know why it's like god i meant cod
systems it's a really weird
system where
you will put appliances in your kitchen
and those appliances each appliance will
have like a card associated with it so
it's like this stove will have two
boil cards and two
uh like simmer cards because you can
simmer and you can boil and then like a
recipe will be like you need to take
this ingredient and boil it and this
ingredient and do this so it's just kind
of like i've come up with a new recipe
so it's a lot of just like taking cards
and like okay i need to take this card
and move it here and then take this
ingredient so it's just kind of like
moving stuff around in menus in a way
that isn't not actually that fun it's
just kind of more annoying and you can
automate it so like and then you can
upgrade where you can just like auto
populate the cards and then eventually
you can get a character that will be
like i'll just cook for you and i was
like please i'm kind of done with this
cooking mini game i don't want to deal
with it i rather you just do it so i
sort of wish that stuff was a little
more
like fun and engaging yeah um cooking in
video games is one of those things where
i either love it or i [ __ ] hate it
like i i i'd be curious i don't know if
i'm sure someone's done it but a video
breakdown of what makes cooking fun and
games and what does it because i think
of something like breath of the wild
where that just felt like experimenting
with [ __ ] yes you pick up objects throw
them in a bowl light a fire cook it and
whatever comes out that's what you get
like like that that to me was super
engaging but then there are other games
i mean xenoblade which which i talked
about last week has cooking and that is
very dependent on finding ingredients
that are scattered around the world and
you don't know
where they are like it'll give you a
broad sense like oh they're in this area
but then you have to find them yeah and
it's kind of a pain
but
it can be so good sometimes it can be so
good i always get excited because i i
like cooking in real life so like
whenever i see a cooking mini game like
i was so stoked when they added cooking
and animal crossing last year yeah and i
was like yeah and it is fun although
there's not many uses yeah you do it and
then you're like i guess i'll put this
baguette over on the table now and it
looks it looks nice very nice i will
give that to someone as a gift later
jake how do you feel about cooking mama
never played it do you play it right now
is it is it on board on my phone really
it's not the one that's like fully yeah
i'm checking out of this podcast
which one was the cooking mama that was
embroiled in a controversy that was the
most recent one
something star
yeah superstar what was the deal with
that one again oh
cooking mama drama i remember a lot of
people thought uh there's like a briefly
there's a rumor going around that like
it was tied to the blockchain and it was
like this thing's gonna mine uh
cryptocurrency if you put it in or
something that turned out to be complete
didn't it just come out of nowhere there
was no developer attached to it or the
developer attached to it wasn't real or
it was something there was some weird
weirdness going around with that that
was bizarre it failed to meet the
standards it's expected apparently yeah
and then they like pulled it from the
store like an hour after it came out
yeah no one had heard it was just a mess
very weird
anyway
the cooking and bear and breakfast is
yeah you just kind of wish it was better
and it
part of it is because you'll do it and
you're like cool i made this recipe and
then you have to populate your once you
make a recipe you have to go to your
dining room and you put it into like the
the serving area
so that your guests can and your guests
will be like i need a level
i want six levels of food
to for me to give this place a five star
so you get more money
and you don't need to make specific food
it's just that food has like a number
associated with it so as long as you
have enough food to hit that number
you're good the problem is that they eat
the food so it kind of just becomes a
chore of like i have to go back to the
kitchen i have to make more food and
then like the menu is just kind of more
annoying than fun so
once i got the upgrade i was like please
take care of all this for me i don't
want to do it which isn't the best that
feels
kind of more just like uh failure to
make the cookie mini game
fun
um but i've been besides that i'm like
i'm having a great time with it like
there's something very satisfying about
like a management sim where you're like
i'm gonna slowly i'm gonna make this the
best damn bed and breakfast that you
have ever been to and i'm gonna upgrade
this and i'm gonna get the right clock
and i'm gonna put it on on my rooms and
i'm gonna make a nice little
hangout area do you make all the rooms
in your bed and breakfast uniform or do
you try and make each one look different
and cool oh i make them uniform because
i don't got time for that [ __ ] okay cool
i'm one of those people who's like each
one of these
is going to be special different
adventure and every single one of them
ends up differently absolutely [ __ ]
awful no no see i'm i'm that like cold
like
business like no i got to get these
these rooms got to be uniform they got
to spare regular business regulated
i got to get you in and i got to get you
out
no frills no frills um cool yeah
enjoying it yeah it's good it's great i
i'm i have a really good time with it
and yeah i'm in the endgame now so i'm
in like the final area um there's three
different
like sections so there's three buildings
i'm like oh so many possibilities
there's a wine cellar apparently that i
haven't built yet and i'm like
so i'm very excited about that how many
hours in are you
um
15 right 15 i think more at this point
probably like 18 19 probably okay
let's go decent chunk of game yeah yeah
you've also been playing
two-point campus i have i've been
playing another management week
we were cycling between the two we were
like all right we're done with vernon
breakfast let's load up two on campus
let's start at university let's start a
university uh i really like two point
hospital i don't know if you guys played
much of that one a couple years ago it's
basically so i think it was
the creators of two point the developer
studios they they came from like those
guys came from lionhead originally and
they worked on like uh
black and white and i think the original
fable a little bit um but like two-point
campus and two-point hospital are kind
of very much like that um
roller coaster tycoon style management
yeah where
yeah theme hospital like you're building
different buildings and you're kind of
trying to get people to go into like um
use your facilities and there's like a
[ __ ] ton of metrics and steps you can
pull up if you really want to get into
it but you can also just kind of ignore
that stuff
and
it's just really it's just a really good
one of those
you know it's campus themed which is fun
so they have fun little like weird
courses like
there you can get like a clown college
um
course going nothing a clown college fan
yes they have a clown college course
there's like a medieval college i don't
think any of us expected him to say that
so now
you have a decision to make
lucy james
you're on the spot
okay
you now have to pick between
two point campus
and the sims
expansion right because that's also
university-based isn't it no it's high
school they already did again high
school or whatever but it's school based
yeah
what are the state like why why does she
have to decide just because for the
purposes of entertainment if i was
playing you see you playing the other
one you're in [ __ ] trouble um well so
i
the
i can't wait now you've activated my
trap card
because we're going one anime expo this
weekend uh
i would play an anime expo convention
simulator convention simulation
you got to set up the artist ally don't
give this away for free quiet yeah
speaking of giving away good ideas for
free though uh alex van aiken yesterday
tweeted that they should make a pokemon
management sim where you create the
gym leaders the region oh you're like
you create the whole league yeah you
create the league you manage which
pokemon appear in different sections you
watch other people go through it and
giving them out for free i know you just
tweeted it out i was like that's that's
a pokemon company put out a game with
one trillion pokemon in it but it wasn't
the entire pokedex and everyone [ __ ]
lost my mind do you think they're gonna
you think that they can release a
management sim and include literally
everything
you didn't include any of the gym
leaders from joe tone
have you seen the other stuff the
pokemon company releases because no one
gives a [ __ ] you know people do it's
like pokemon masters do you know what
that is no neither do i but it's on
mobile and a lot of people play
yeah
pokemon masters ex they're putting out a
big update for it i think it's like a
game it is it's a real game pokemon
sleep and pokemon sleep that's not right
pokemon sleep it's a it's a pokemon app
that helps you sleep but uh it's been
delayed for like 30 years so you're
sleeping every now and then one of the
pokemons just quietly comes up here and
goes
[Laughter]
pokemon say their name you know
they don't go
all right what if it's just that really
awful like digital
game boy one sound effect just
that's the noise
they make that's true i remember i
tweeted about it and i tweeted about it
like you got in trouble i got literally
right people threatening to kill me like
in my dms being like
people were like i'm gonna find you and
i'm gonna slit your throat in your sleep
that was one of the dm's that i got i
was like [ __ ] i'd like to see you try
[ __ ]
um anyway the pokemon moba game there's
a lot of pokemon games out there pokemon
unite i would love to play like a
management because can you imagine
you're like the shadowy person that
decides the fate of all these 10 year
olds giovanni
what if you could just say like i don't
like that kid professor give them a [ __ ]
starter
but also
create your gym leaders choose what type
they're going to use pokemon they're
going to use yeah and then you so
observe and then you observe and you go
like they're beating gym leader three a
little too quickly we need to up we need
to change yeah so you're basically
trying to create the perfect league to
ruin a pokemon trainer's life or you're
trying to create like the perfect
pokemon gym already exists and then jim
is brock's gym when you're playing
[ __ ] pokemon yellow and you just
really have a pikachu pikachu yeah and
if you don't know it's gonna catch the
monkey we should call it the game will
be called the pokemon failure league
yeah and and your whole thing is to
construct a world of pokemon where you
try and make every trainer fail
or just make them see i feel like that's
just actually you're kind of teaching
people how to like
craft a good balanced like rpg of like
oh you know um in the chat leveling and
people are talking about pokemon
what is this cafe
oh yeah oh yeah cafe mix which yeah
they're putting mewtwo in there or
something
said it likes uh it's like candy crush
right i've never played it
oh i have yeah there's a i googled
pokemon ex where's the pokemon cooking
mini game and there's a lot of pictures
there's that one where you make curry
yeah but like pokeblocks but where i
cook the pokemon
have they ever talked about whether they
eat pokemon in what they do yeah they
eat well they eat slow poke tails they
eat magic carbs
yeah i mean the slow potatoes apparently
the tails regrow so it's fine yeah wait
wait wait
uh hey in the chat says did y'all see
mewtwo fought in the pokemon showcase
i missed that part and pokemon showcase
on wednesday damn fighting well that
answers my question doesn't youtube i
didn't realize that mewtwo was a wind
type pokemon there are wind type
pokemons
um because edmund says which pokemon are
deserving of death
which pokemon is
in the pokemon detective pikachu movie
oh yeah oh major mr mind makes that
movie
oh yeah yeah
i don't like mine yeah mine junior's the
blue one right yeah it looks terrible
it looks like like
it looks like something cold or turned
out
i mean nothing wrong with that that's
the natural process so
what was the question again which
pokemon deserve death deserve death well
according to the audience none of them
ever
um yeah i've typed in worst pokemon of
all time oh what's that one that looks
like a uh like a
i was gonna say paperclip what the [ __ ]
is that
yeah which one i don't know the name of
that some weird fish
rainbow looking fish rainbow looking
fish stun fisk this is an article
written by uh keema
former
um i mean probably bee drill because
it's just a a hornet beedrill yeah i
mean i'm okay with beedrill wait was
that giant hornet oh no oh no are i okay
i don't care about that but are we
basing them off of like
their attitude or just like i don't like
the way you look
oh zubat yeah hey look at this one
oh sock suck my balls
[Laughter]
how did you not see that how the hell
did you walk
[Laughter]
um i hate this place
welcome back welcome back welcome back
oh my god um yeah these [ __ ] there's
some real [ __ ] but there's one called
watchdog oh it's just a giant [ __ ]
[ __ ] looking chipmunk no there's one
that's got trump hair that's pretty bad
oh what is it um
there's a pokemon called licky
i think they look cute i like look at
this one's called licky icky
he's just look at his dumbbell smile
damn we need to hook up your laptop to
like yeah
eventually there's
you should probably move on from this
because it's just a staring at tam's
screening yeah it is wasn't this wasn't
this originally number one on this list
of paris
which paris is fine yeah
this is a lot worse rubbish okay okay
here's the thing though if you think of
the actual um
like lore behind paris and parasect
super [ __ ] up that's the last of a
[ __ ] i actually don't even know oh the
whole thing is fungus took over the
mushroom yeah the mushroom on top of it
took over and like basically mind
controls the creature like the cordyceps
and last of us so no that's that's dope
drunk
from the pokemon universe yet again
he doesn't have any original ideas no
ideas
gets it off
on campus
yeah two point campus it's cool you get
to uh yeah did you enroll in clown
college or no uh yeah i started a
college college school yeah you like
and you can there's like weird you can
have like clubs so it's like oh
everyone's gonna join the sleep club
where they can like learn how to manage
sleep better which means that they can
like they don't have to go back to their
rooms as often so it's yeah it's just i
don't know it's just a fun good
management time um
it's extremely [ __ ] british oh yeah
yeah two point studios are british i
wish i wrote down some of the names some
of the names were just like
i had i had uh i had someone uh that was
a janitor and his name was like
jack off or something
and i was like ah
jack offman yeah it was like i don't
think jack offerman jack off uh
i'm gonna message georgia to take a
photo of the uh
but how is dr pebble saying behind you
turn around
uh no i'm scared uh but there's a
there's a food in that called uh cheesy
grubbins
and then they like because the whole
thing is like there's a radio that kind
of like talks about them and then you
you'll have like a sponsor come in and
it's like this guy he's like i'm the
cheesy gremlin from cheesy grubbins and
i'm here to come around and spread the
joy of cheesy grubbins and i'm like
thank you here's
give me my five thousand dollars how
easy is it for people who might not be
super
experienced with management sims to get
into
i think it's pretty easy um it
definitely can get
difficult later on but i think it does a
so
one thing i really like about it is
there are multiple
um
you take something like the
uh like roller coaster tycoon where it
just kind of like throws you in the deep
end and you're just like oh i i don't
really know what to do yeah
in this
it has objectives that it's like hey
like make this then do this and i kind
of like you'll get like a star system
and so you constantly have goals to
shoot for
and each uh campus you do
starts off kind of pretty basic where
it's like okay you just need to all you
need to do is like get you know your
students to have all c's and you know
for this course and then once you unlock
the next campus you go to that they'll
introduce like all right we're now gonna
add this new like we're gonna have the
clown college now and we're gonna do
this so i think it does a pretty good
job of like slowly integrating its
systems over time as opposed to
um just like throwing you in the deep
end and you just have all these options
and you're like i don't know what the
[ __ ] any of this is so i i think it's
very approachable
um
and a good time very british
extremely british we'll see you guys
in the chat says that reminds me of
master bates from oliver twist
was it olivia twist was it wasn't it the
um
uh the the the ship one and it was like
roger dick no it was like master bates
and roger the cabin boy were the two
famous ones
oh you've been watching
um
final fantasy
yeah uh so on the podcast of i think
like beginning of the year maybe it was
a while ago i said that i was starting
final fantasy 9 i have now beaten final
fantasy
uh well first things first i met the
creator of captain pugwash
um it was interesting
final fantasy 9 you finished it did you
like it i loved it
why not why did you pick nine um we've
been going through all of the
playstation one
so we oh good lord so how many of you if
you've just been playing through
so we we started with um
so
back when remake came out what two years
ago now 2020 yeah i was like man i
really like that game i should go play
the original seven because i've never
played it went and played that had a
good time enjoyed it
and then said okay we should just keep
going played eight
hated it i did not like eight oh i'm
sorry to all the people that like ate is
that the weird one with like the hockey
team yeah
yeah
i i thought i was gonna be all in on it
and to be for the hockey team part's
pretty good but the lagoon is great
there's individual characters and
moments that are good but like the
overall story i thought was like
bad
i did not like
damn what happens in final fantasy 8 i
have no idea
there's a bunch of gardens
there's beef
um
altamecia who's the villain altamisia do
you know where her deal is she's
ultimate seer
okay
i don't remember i remember
understanding at the time and i was
thinking this is just high school teen
drama in in a weird sci-fi setting
i was just like it's trying to do way
too much because it's like high school
drama but then it's like but also
they're like child mercenary soldiers
and also there's a time traveling witch
that you have to murder ultimately and
then there's a moon where monsters rain
from the sky
it sounds cool it but it makes no
[ __ ] sense it's fine
it's got zel in it okay that's all that
matters zell's great he likes to punch
stuff
azalea indeed and then he does an
uppercut and dolphins come out
it's fantastic it's brilliant
um
in chat the moon drips a big ball of
monsters onto the earth so that this
witch can collapse time question mark
nailed it yeah what is the witch's name
altimeter hell yeah
um nine is my favorite though nine is
excellent so so yeah i went from like
seven is pretty good
eight i did not like and i was like all
right i don't know about this final
fantasy thing i'm i'm
one for
one for one one for one or one for two
what yeah um but then nine just
immediately from the gecko
just like
captures you with like what's happening
with its characters i wasn't confused i
understood the stakes
everyone's so clearly defined uh i think
just it it feels like such a
pitch perfect jrpg to me in terms of
just like the the the party roster
the events the um the combat like
everything about it just felt like
like a perfect
game
like i would like i would i would i
would
describe it as almost like a perfect
game like
as far as like a jrpg goes like i i
can't i've failed the only thing that's
bad about it is the trance system is
garbage but that's like the one thing
that's bad about it but and also it gets
it's got some really unexpected
difficulty spikes it does out of nowhere
it does get absolutely kind of difficult
in spots that's true destroy you did you
fight ark uh
ark is like a hidden boss it's just a
giant ship no i didn't fight that one i
thought that was being like one of the
hardest bosses i fought satan i thought
that one okay i think i don't remember
that um i just thought the ones that i
like knew i was gonna get like stuff i
wanted out of so it was i'm trying to
remember it's been so long since i
played i only played this nine once i
remember it being like of these
of the playstation era it was the one
that i liked the most
um it's got the best characters
yeah it's a dance main character
garnet uh steiner's
a very wide boy yes he's excellent uh
queena queen is great queen is like a
giant licky tongue yeah it's like it's
like this weird creature with a giant
tongue who's just obsessed with uh
eating food and cooking
and it's like kind of the joke character
because every
doesn't quinn have like a weird
backstory queen it does have like a
weird backstory uh they like live in a
swamp and there's like a minigame where
you collect frogs yeah that's the one
like shrek yeah like shrek yes they're
basically shrek again everything yeah
they just reference and then there's the
little
is it kuja kujo
one of the characters the red hair
maybe there's the red haired one right
um
oh oh oh um
emirate
kuja
kuja no wait could you just someone else
amaranth amaranth you're thinking of
amaranth the big coochie's the main bait
bait guy
yeah bad guy yeah kucha's the bad guy
okay yeah um yeah you're thinking of
amaranth they're really like tall oh
yeah yeah yeah uh he's okay he's
probably the weakest character that's
hot top streams on top
what
i was thinking of amaranth oh my god i
was like
is that what my categorize does now
uh but it has i think it just has like
such a perfect cast i think the
narrative is just pitch perfect um i
like when went away from that game being
like damn this is like
maybe one of my favorite it's good that
she's ever played it's really good i
really love the uh the opening
theater scene
where you i think are you doing like
fencing or like you're doing a you do
like a fight while the play is happening
you do it yeah at some point because it
reveals that the the play is just a
facade to kidnap the princess and then
like at some point you're like doing a
fight and at first you're doing like a
fake fight as part of the play and then
you're doing it it becomes a real fight
yeah and the audience still thinks it's
like a part of the play which is really
good
nine holds up really it holds up
extremely well it also
it
it feels like it's it's like a the
perfect send-off to like that era or
final fantasy because it's i think it's
the last game that
uh sakaguchi had any real involvement in
at all like he was kind of like the
producer and i think he helped the
script and after that he pretty much
bowed out um working on like final
fantasy directly
so
like and then like all the different
like characters and names there's a lot
of nods to final fantasy 4 specifically
apparently um it just that it's like
my because i played with my brother and
he kind of described it as it's a game
that makes me feel incredibly nostalgic
for an era of video games that i don't
actually have any nostalgia for because
i never actually played these games as a
kid
but like just playing it i was like oh
man like i'm just like i'm feeling it
i'm feeling like the the love of like
all these old like final fantasy games
and it felt like i was playing like the
last great one before it kind of
moved over i actually played it on an
original playstation one okay
it is on steam though i just checked
interesting i might check it out
it's really good i haven't played many
final fantasy games but i was curious
are you going to go on to 10 or are you
done you played 10 though right no i
haven't played 10.
so that's funny yeah like i say all this
i've only ever played my final fantasy
experiences i tried 13
and i bounced off of it i tried 15 and i
bounced off of it
i've tried a little bit of 14 and i've
i'm attempting to stick with it we'll
see how that goes have you tried 12 no i
haven't played any of the ps4 i tried
final fantasy 9.
zodiac gage is so good like system and
that's what i use so it's like now that
i've yeah and it's basically star wars
it's like basically any that's what i've
heard so now that i've played all the ps
ones i'm like time to go to ps2 i think
i'm gonna actually stick with the ps1
and play like
a couple of playstation one rpgs that i
missed like
vagrant stories one uh chrono cross um
maybe final fantasy tactics i heard that
one's pretty good yeah tactical is great
peter brown
but you should definitely play 10 is so
much fun no i'm really excited to get to
it um
but yeah played it on the original
playstation one because i'm a i'm a nerd
like that hooked it up to my crt and
everything it was like oh i'm gonna play
like that uh but i've heard like the
parts are pretty good which one ten of
nine nine uh i've i've never played a
port i played a bit of it on psp
vito one
[Music]
one of those two i remember like
the black mage fights being like
particularly rough and i was like oh oh
man um did you know that so
uh that game has also i think it's just
like the peak of like that uh
playstation one sort of like uh
well what do you call it where like the
the backdrops are are all like fake yeah
yeah yeah um like it's like the peak of
that design yeah it looks so good though
hold on we have discord notifications
is that me that's just us hold on
um but like you know uh final fantasy
vii
uh a revolutionary at the time pretty
rough to go back to presentation wise
doesn't look great uh i think eight is
like a huge leap up but like nine just
feels like it's like the victory lap
like we have perfected
our like tech on the playstation 1. it
looks so nice i remember being blown
away by it back in the day
even today still looks pretty good one
cut scene in particular where they like
blend uh like the 3d character running
with like the like a pre-rendered
cutscene and i was just like damn even
like today i would be like i would have
no idea how to do this this is
impressive there's some like backgrounds
and like areas in that game that are
like so detailed that you can like
really get lost in them yeah like i'm
looking at one now that carnival area
yes okay i don't know what run around
that for ages and and
uh it's a shame because i think like the
ps the pc port
is like it doesn't look great like like
because they kind of blow those up and
try and like art
ai generate but people have found out
that there apparently are there do exist
high-res asset versions of some of those
backgrounds so there is a modding
project where people are trying to like
put those back into the pc version the
problem is i think only like some of
them exist
and
because square didn't do the greatest
job
archiving that stuff
but that's a it's a bomb so you're going
out to ten now right yeah i'll
eventually go on to ten we're taking a
little bit of a break cause i'm playing
the reason it took me so long is because
i play it with my brother um over like
parsec um and we would just play like a
few hours every sunday like for the last
like couple months so we're taking a
little bit of a break and then we'll
eventually get 10's good 12 is really
good
um so you're in for a good few years
those were the only two no ten ten two
ten two is basically
ten
what if ten was a j-pop video game see i
think that's the one that george is
going to probably really like because
she's been starts off with a literal
j-pop concert excellent and it is
[ __ ] great i listen to the soundtrack
that is massively underaid i think um
yeah yeah we she's been with us the
whole time but like it's kind of like
dipped in and out of interest because i
think it's just kind of hard for her to
like engage with some of that if she
wants to invest in 10-2 she needs to
kind of be there i think for 10. okay so
i'll tell her that like here yeah you
just gotta you gotta stick with ten yeah
so you can get pretend it's very easy to
stick with because it's got some very
like
interesting or like very it's very
cinematic
oh yeah yeah it's probably better i
think i think eight is what pushed her
out because she did she also did not
like eight she was like i don't know
yeah [ __ ] is going on with the [ __ ] ken
like opens and it's like a banger from
the very house yeah so so you'll have a
good time i've played ten maybe like
five or six times
um it's just the most like i feel
playable of them all yeah like most fun
to jump in and out of and you get
titus's laugh too you got to see titus
yeah
the titular tightest laugh the titular
tightest laugh you also get to meet oren
who's one of the coolest characters in
video games you might remember him from
kingdom hearts
do you think i'll be able to find any
good like vv figures at crunchyroll or
something like i'm looking around do you
think there's nine a little more niche
nine that's quite nice but he's more
like there's definitely sure
figures online right he is like one of
the most beloved
vivi and why are you looking
um but also there's a one p you'll
definitely find vv figures but it will
be from one piece okay different vv yeah
i want vivi and i want freya
uh jess was in the chat earlier and said
that aquina is actually one of the first
uh non-binary video game characters they
are they kind of mess it up in the
translation a little bit because instead
of calling them
they them because that exists the
translators just gave up so everyone
just calls her he she
which is really really weird yeah just
in it they're just like oh i don't know
he she went that way and i was like guys
they they exist
it's a term you could have just used
that like i don't know why they didn't
just go with that it's a very strange
it's a word it was a word you could have
used it yeah um but yeah 90s
localization or no 2 000 2000 2 000 yeah
um
yeah so final fantasy 9 success yes
success excellent game another person
playing final fantasy
yeah
back on 14
baby are you still getting up in the
morning and just getting through uh a
little bit kind of slowed down because i
have to go into the office now and i
don't have as much time to kill in the
morning you know i gotta i gotta shower
brush my teeth eat all that stuff so
don't have quite as much time but i have
been playing it i think i'm over halfway
through heaven's work now
enjoying it uh a lot more now that i'm
out of the original area the the realm
reborn stuff it still hasn't quite
clicked with me as hard as it has other
people you haven't cried yet i haven't
cried yet uh but i think
i think it's going to take more time for
that okay i think it's going to take a
little more time can you feel
emotions being stirred by it
um
slightly slightly
they're they're setting up the pieces
but if they don't pull it off i don't
think i am is always crying about it but
haim's the worst marker of emotional
that's true he cries at everything yeah
so kirby made him cry man cry neal made
him cry
like he'll play tetris and cry yeah if
you guys i will say the music is [ __ ]
incredible yeah and
if anything's gonna make me cry it'll
probably be the music mixed with a
little bit of emotion that the
characters give out
um i've heard nothing but good things
about that soundtrack yeah it's it's
very good i've even been listening to
the heavensward soundtrack on spotify
i'm not done with the game yet
yeah there are songs there that are
incredible my
the thing that sucks i i well i want to
try now that there's world travel i
think they added that a couple updates
ago where john luke we can actually play
together now yeah uh because right now i
feel like i'm kind of in a little box
when i play final fantasy 14 because i'm
in a separate server then you michael
ben um i have one friend who was the one
who walked me through a realm reborn
who's in that server he was the one who
told me to join that server so he could
walk me through it which to be fair
i don't know if michael or ben or anyone
would have the time to actually ben i'm
sure if i asked him he'd be like i'd
make time but to be fair
my friend offered so i was like okay
i'll join that server and now he is
playing xenoblade so he halted his
subscription so i'm on my own now
and it is
a little lonely i would say okay okay
you know like we're playing destiny
because i've been playing a little bit
of destiny too but we're playing destiny
it's nice because playing with you and
callie and we're yeah
you know we're doing missions together
and final fantasy feels like a solo
experience
to be fair apparently that's why it
works so well as a story-based mmo is
because
that story is told from your character's
perspective i mean
yeah i guess every mmo kind of is but
you know what i'm trying to say uh
so yeah i uh i'm still playing it i'm at
least gonna get through heaven's word
if heaven's word really hooks me i'm
gonna keep going mm-hmm
but as of now
i think if heavens where it ended now i
would probably stop okay but there's
more to do interesting
i'm still interested in getting back to
it but
i've got a lot going on oh i don't
actually but yeah it's a it's a time
commitment but i do appreciate that
people have talked about this before but
uh they do a pretty good job of
making it easy to level up up front for
that at the beginning of the week and
then if you can keep playing sure but
your gains are going to decrease
pretty heavily
so
it doesn't make a lot of sense to just
play
12 hours at a time like it's better play
you know run a dungeon a day or
something like that yeah spartan chris
in the chat says i stopped having
heavensward as well it's fun but it's
such a time commitment so
you've got to be prepared to spend a lot
of hours um georgia sent me the name the
british name that way
please it was uh a janitor named godfrey
pudding and his picture was him dabbing
his picture was dabbing and i was like
that man yeah
straight up it's some good there's some
good humor in that free pudding uh jack
you mentioned destiny
yeah i actually don't have much to say
about it because i haven't played a
whole lot but john luke is kind of
walking me through trying to get back
into destiny what i want to talk about
though is multiverses because oh
wait are you playing now well
i played the closed beta
wasn't wild about it uh i thought it had
some neat ideas but it didn't feel great
apparently
they addressed a lot of those issues
that other people had
uh
and apparently the full release game is
much
better or in a better state
that said i still don't like that game
um
you don't like playing arya stark versus
batman i mean that's cool
i think i think the game itself is dope
and i'm happy they're bringing all these
characters together and i'm happy people
are getting into this but
as someone who plays smash bros
regularly it just feels like crap to me
i just don't like playing it i
don't what is it about it that feels bad
because we put a review up we got 8 out
of 10.
and
there's not based on everyone that i see
talking about they say it feels good so
i think i'm a little biased here because
i
i think
it's less that the game feels bad and
more than i'm so used to how smash bros
feels that playing multiverses
i found very difficult and i was gonna
say how many hours do you have in smash
now at this point like 600 or something
uh and and that is just on my console
and to be fair a lot of the smash i play
is on other people's comments well
because you you walk in and just
demolish them at home and then just
leave exactly yeah um
so i i don't know i'm happy people are
enjoying it and i think it's cool that
it's good and i think they've have a
really cool foundation of how they're
going to update it regularly add more
characters that's something that i wish
smash bros was made
uh it was built with that in mind like
yeah they had the battle pass but after
that battle pass they were done
uh the the online and smash not great
i think multiverses definitely beats out
beats it out in terms of online play but
for me just that momentum on gameplay is
it just it just feels too sticky i guess
i don't know are you playing on your own
i i played a little bit with some
friends and then i've done a couple
matches solo
did you do the 2v2 mode or the
free-for-all 2v2 okay yeah that's the
main thing that they have going right
like two which is which i i once again
i'll say i think it's cool because a lot
of the characters are built for that and
it's cool how people experiment with
different characters and how different
characters work in unison
but
to me like yeah sure that's cool but it
just doesn't feel right
and it's hard to describe and
but but smash bros is just i've spent
i've spent so much time with smash bros
it's really hard for me to i had the
same thing with the nickelodeon all-star
brawls
that game did not feel good no no
firstly yeah firstly how much is
nintendo paying you to say all this
secondly i wish yeah
i wish they were playing i think like
the other games that have been smashed
like have just been outright not good
yeah i i play those and i'm like i
played those a couple of them i was like
this is just like very pale imitation
from the little i've played of
multiverses i'm like
i feel like it's a
considerably better game than any smash
clone that i agree previously it's
still not as good as smash but i think
it's got a lot of potential um i think
that
it's
perhaps the only game that has come out
since the entire like since the first
ever smash clone i don't know what it
would be like i know jump all-stars or
even like battle royale that can
actually hang with
exist alongside smash um and i think
that's a pretty big market because smash
is still
one it's
locked on one platform
so its um player base is going to be
limited by that virtue two it's like not
free to play whereas
multiverses is
three like
they are going to keep shoving
characters into that thing for a long
time i reckon yeah is that now what's
going to say
they've had to delay the first season i
mean like i they would have already had
the the uh contracts in place for yeah
the upcoming sleigh of characters ted
lasso was rumored to be added ted lasso
um but i think that's dead lasso over
roy kent that's mad yeah i know although
although if they're if we're getting uh
you know
discovery what what what richard
ambrough let's go yeah let's go say your
favorite trash where's uh zach baggins
[ __ ] yeah zach bacon
no wait she's tlc is that the same i
don't know zach baggins uh the property
brothers big ed um
oh big head um oh yeah the the 90 day
fiance uh
yeah that's incredibly big versus uh
mythbusters
uh adam and jamie or buster
discovery plus what was even on there uh
work for mythbusters couldn't yeah like
let's get james yeah
yeah in multiverses
uh yes uh trixie uh trixie motel so
technically you could you they could put
trixie in
that then i'd play it oh wait deadliest
catch so um some fish just a giant and
dinosaur the boat dinos drive-ins and
dives so you could technically get a guy
oh [ __ ] that would be dope if they put
guys see this is what i'm saying their
potential
okay it's off the track
i am just looking at some [ __ ] shows
that they make and brian altano did like
a very funny photoshop earlier about
like fake shows they're in the discovery
plus thing and one of them is called
stop sending me clocks
but so they actually have shows in here
called oh okay this one i love a mama's
boy i've seen clips of on tick-tock
uh which is terrifying where it's like
the dude in the relationship was just
like obsessed with his mum and there was
this one clip where he was like i know i
got a sexy mom and he like hats are on
the ass oh my god it's 90 day fiance on
uh yeah
yeah okay so big ed comes from naked and
afraid
oh yeah
um we've got
sino-e oh how it's made yeah how it's
made voiceover yes that's what uh
someone in the chat just said the voice
from how it's made pretty cool
yeah
married at first sight gold rush ancient
aliens wait i'm afraid we've got the
winner
hold on doctor pimple pop
i was going to yeah get dr pimple popper
in yeah multiverses but yeah i i think
gordon ramsay yeah of course where is uh
behind the magician's
face
surely because we can get val valentino
in there
magicians
imagine netflix is getting into games
right when what are they making their
smash clone
yeah put the strangers for the stranger
things the problem is is that they've
cancelled all of their characters i want
like the live-action cowboy bebop people
to fight like the people from bridgeton
or something like this
um but yeah i think i think it has
potential yeah game i feel like for the
people that i know that aren't like as
into smash
or like are more capable of just like
pivoting to other games they seem to be
very into it yeah i agree i i think i
mean
all in all i think it's pretty cool and
i'm stoked that people are enjoying it
and i'm stoked that it's got the
reception it it it's getting because
i want
more smash clones i get not clones but i
want more games in that space because
for so long smash just kind of dominated
it i mean there's what playstation
all-stars
oh yeah that was another one that was a
game
so i think it's cool but for me
personally i don't think i can go back i
mean it's
smash feels so good it feels so
responsive so snappy
uh i i
all the characters have the right weight
to them i don't really feel that in
multiverses a lot of characters just
feel the same to be fair i've only
played like four or five i haven't i've
not played
i've played arya stark superman
wonder woman uh harley quinn and i tried
to play lebron but i didn't have i
didn't have enough
whatever
yeah warner bucks to get lebron
apparently he's experimental i do like
that too how they label characters that
are experimental which kind of makes me
think that
they might change this character it
could change around and that's something
that
like i i love smash but i think that's
something that that
franchise could use because they'll
release a character that's really broken
and sure they'll tweak it but
i mean broken's not the right word i
think they balance them
as much as they can at least for casual
play but every now and then i think
there's a character that needs to be
rethought like i i like sometimes their
move set just doesn't match the modern
interpretation of that character i think
samus is probably a good example
of just having samus might be good but
there's a couple characters that it's
like where the [ __ ] does this move come
from it's just
it's just random it doesn't doesn't work
but
uh it was probably me in the chat says
sounds like playing ghost of sashima i
assume after playing sakura
uh yeah probably that's that's probably
how i felt because i didn't stick with
ghost tsushima
or or just like any of the like um
like i tried like mortal coil or like
you know some of those other like from
souls likes and and they all have like
their own thing but i'm always just like
that just doesn't just feel this doesn't
have that miyazaki touch yes yeah
multiverse doesn't have that sakurai
magic yeah yeah it was his birthday the
other day happy birthday
and no one else um honestly james
hatfield from metallica
my favorite part about smash was like
not even playing it was just i was
excited for a new character because i
was really excited to watch those videos
soccer i was just sitting there at his
desk yeah just or in his home
yeah and then he's just like i'm gonna
play the character and he's like making
jokes with the like crew and you can
hear like the camera people behind
laughing and he describes how he plays
two characters at once with
you know he's so pleasant when he has
the [ __ ] uh
he's so pleasant that it leads me to
believe that when the cameras are off
he's probably like a tyrant no no
no he probably immediately goes to sleep
yeah yeah i think he's like out there he
leaves and smokes off
kind of cigarettes
around punching kill children maybe not
to punch in but smoking lots of
cigarettes uh my favorite saccharide
tweet was after the battle passes ended
he took a picture of a plushie he had of
one of the uh among us
characters and he said now i can tweet
this because people won't think it's
coming to smash
or he's like i can tweet my plushie
collection because people oh yeah that
man like i'm sure anything he ever
posted on twitter was just screw nine
smash
yeah people would write up articles like
certain websites would just write up
entire articles of a picture he posted
if he had it if he had any
if i was a social media manager i'd go
to like pornhub find a porn star and
post a picture of that and people would
be like smash
[Laughter]
and that would be your last name
this man will not be in smash
um lucy what you've been playing
uh well i've been playing two point
hospital
i have been playing call of the lamb
can't talk about that uh and i've
watched the sandman i can't talk about
that sweet
so i will say
i um
i'm growing
more annoyed at the fact that i don't
have a steam deck yeah you are insane
has it got anything to do with me
constantly sending you pictures of steam
deck i went to the millers last night
and i was talking to greg about uh
colton the lamb and he just went
it's so great to have a steam deck i
don't think [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you hate
pc gaming and he's like oh steve deck's
great there's a game i can't talk about
that i've been playing on the steam deck
and it's pretty cool
i don't know if so last week another one
yeah
i was so annoyed that i didn't have a
steam deck and i wanted to play bear and
breakfast and um
the other games i've been playing on my
couch
these are real poverty hours what she's
about to explain is like well i
no no no so i
realized and you can't talk because i
was texting you throughout the year
i was like holy [ __ ] i
[ __ ] um
discovered that my tv tam and i bought
the same tv in the same black friday
sale
um
has the steam link app on it already
and apparently
according to my
very rudimentary googling uh if you
are on the same network and both are
plugged into your uh router i'm not
saying
how american router stop it's disgusting
um
and uh it doesn't use it barely uses any
data
so i was there using steam link uh with
a controller
in my pc uh just playing bear and
breakfast except bearing breakfast
doesn't have controller support at a
minute so
right trigger was like click
the space bar was a like it was a mess
and i couldn't keep doing it but
i was playing a bunch of cult the lamb
and i was playing a lot of uh i was
about to say theme hospital two-point
campus on that and that was really good
steam link is very fun it's very good
yeah i so
when i started at gamespot someone gave
me one of the original steam link things
that you plug in
and it was awful it was a miserable
experience we had pretty fast internet
too at the time i remember trying to
play witcher 3 and it was
stuttering the entire time
uh but i've heard it's gotten much
better now it's a great experience it's
pretty good i've been curious to check
it out because
i spent enough time sitting at my desk
that's exactly what i was like doing
work too much time on my desk um so i
did that but the other thing i've been
playing is uh i did get
uh sims 4 high school years
that game is really broken in a minute
like it's really broken at the minute
well uh they have patched out incest
they patched out the incest good for
them
uh no i
so i mean the incest stuff aside i
luckily didn't get hit girls win again
oh my gosh
i like they didn't get hit with the like
the auto um age up bug but i know george
george george's textile group third and
she was like i'm accidentally in i've
accidentally got a whole neighborhood of
seniors now
um
but like even
the uh the curved walls are really
bugged um there's a lot of other stuff
going on i have a sim currently and i
haven't actually even done the high
school stuff yet because i built a
family in preparation and the baby's
just been born and i want to like age
them up and then take him to school uh
but the the husband of the family is
constantly on like a sliver of sleep
need and he won't that need won't fill
up even if i send him to bed and i even
use cheats to like refill his needs and
it just stuck there and i'm just like
oh okay i might have to kill you because
this is annoying
i
if you don't get the sleep you need it
does feel like death so
um
canadian spoon don't worry about it you
can get a you can get a mod for that
yeah i downloaded an installed sims but
now do they remove the insert so i'm
just going to uninstall that at this
point there's mods for that
i want to know what priority
incest falls in like when you receive
bugs at a developer developer you sort
them in terms of priority right so how
how much is this going to affect the
user how much attention should we focus
on this how soon should we tackle it
versus something smaller like oh this
player has having trouble connecting
obviously we want to look into it but we
can't do it right away clearly uh i want
to know where incest falls it goes above
old people yeah
exactly genuinely don't think
i think if it hadn't been picked up
because people were like immediately
news the reddit was on fire i don't i
think if it hadn't gotten that that wide
spread but unfortunately someone sent an
email to the sims team being like
but also it's because like they changed
the the wants and need system to be more
in line with like older sims games and
like apparently there's just like sims
walking around going like yeah we want
to
shag family
is that is that log back into work at 9
00 p.m to fix or is that i'll wait until
tomorrow yes
you need to go back to the office right
now i think that's from an executive
level log in at nine but from a
developer level we'll fix that tomorrow
yeah yeah
so what time we're working on i've been
playing i've been playing quite a lot um
i should get a steam deck and then
download the sims onto this i'm trying
yeah just get a steam deck it's daddy
yeah yeah yeah
they put it available now i've got six
of them they pushed me back to cueva
yeah they've finally started to fix the
supply issues yeah they said if you
order one now it should
you should be getting it
this year yeah no no no if you've
already ordered one announced that you
get it this year so we're good got a
message i got a picture from young
andrew goldfarb playing eldon ring on
his one
i was like well me too great job
he's figured it out um
but now so uh yeah and also
[Music]
uh
sandman
which i can talk about later
uh
i have been playing a little video game
called
cyberpunk 2017
did you not play it before no i totally
happened with my cyberpunk oh yeah it
just broke right well it kept they kept
releasing 30 gig updates for it and i
was on
my internet was like
hilariously bad or whatever
it was sonic yeah say it again sonic if
you're watching sonic you're a [ __ ]
disgrace okay
top to bottom your internet is
beyond [ __ ] and your customer service is
also dog [ __ ] so how's your sonic
internet going by the way jake it's
better than that but i'm supposed to get
gigabit internet and it's definitely not
that they don't give a [ __ ] they do not
care one minute you didn't even have the
like
i had like the [ __ ] internet package i
call them and i was like can i upgrade
our package please and the person on the
other side was like you can and we will
take your money but you will not get
faster internet and i was like
i can't believe you are saying this to
me
to my face if you want to give us more
money yeah take it what i love is that
they were like they when they set it up
they told me to install a app called
eros which i can call the [ __ ] euro
ero eros i don't know so i can manage my
routers and there's a speed test there
oh and the speed test always says
like one thousand megabytes up there
they're live
they're licensed i can i can be right
next to router i can plug directly into
the router they're
like 200
this is something i figured out like
they would do this thing where their
customer service would be like okay i'm
just going to run some tests
yeah and then they'll be like we're just
conducting a speed test and they'll be
like oh it says you're you've got full
speed here i'm like
it says i have
0.1 megabytes
and like they think that everyone's
stupid as well so they're like
at one point i was like i work in
technology like i know how this stuff
works i'm very online yes i am online
all the time and they were like no we've
got the phone you know who i am i work
for giantbomb.com
you were there when i was setting up my
uh internet with
18.
and they were like oh so you know trying
to talk about like what package i need
and they were like what what do you um
are you gonna be using the internet for
and i just went well for my sins i'm a
gamer
you said that out loud and then uh it
would have been a long day of moving but
then i had uh issues with it where
i was getting really slow speeds and i
was talking to the guy and he said oh
what are you having issues with and i
said i'm trying to download a game and
it's going really really slowly and he
said oh what are you playing i like
final fantasy 14. and so we had a nice
little chat about gaming
but yeah so i haven't had an issue since
so long ago final fantasy
gamer yeah
he's like i bet you listing this account
he's like actively checking in on the
account every day it still works okay
still still getting started still gaming
opened steam today yeah so like i got
the game when it first came out or pre
before it first came out it took me like
a day to download it and then the next
day i was like all right gonna play this
game and because the game was so [ __ ]
they had issued a patch by that point
yeah so it'll be like here's a 30 gig
patch and i was like okay that's one day
i can no longer play this again so it's
a pre-launch it would yeah and then the
launch and then the same stuff so like
four or five times they kept putting out
massive patches that took me entire days
to download and play and then when i got
it eventually up and running it was bug
to [ __ ] for me like i could not play it
was like and i had a 2070 super back
then so i could have run it perfectly
fine or 2080 super one of those two a
good card basically um
and i just could not play it so it
basically reached a point where i was
like i
i'm about eating this until it gets
sorted out i even bought it on
playstation and then that's when the
playstation drama started happening
it broke on playstation and then they
shut it and then they were like we're
shutting it down and i was like
i just cannot play this game that's
because no one could test the
playstation version here at least
exactly so like i just i just abandoned
cyberpunk and i was like i'm gonna
forget and then i
i completed um resident evil 3 on stream
and i was like i need this new stream
game
and the chat was like cyberpunk
um so i started playing cyberpunk and so
far i'm only like an hour or so in but
the gun play feels good they apparently
changed a lot they changed they did it
it did not feel like that when i played
it
originally but like i was
shooting some stuff and i was like this
feels really good like crunchy and nice
and um i've got a 30 90 obviously like
maxing out that ray tracing i i turned
raymond tracing off immediately because
um i find it annoying no no no okay it's
got dlss there's no it does like fake
ray tracing as well but well no dlss
isn't fake the other thing the other
thing it does fake ray tracing and comma
it has the lss as well sorry what is
fake ray tracing well it doesn't give
you the actual ray tracing it does like
a version of that's how i got ray
tracing running on my 20 ae super i
don't know what you i have no idea what
you're talking about i think it's that i
might be mis
i don't know i don't know what that
means
anyway i'll double check later and send
you a screenshot so there's two types of
ray tracing yeah there's there's the
reflections and then there's the global
global illumination yeah turn on the
global illumination if you can because
that's the that's what i think i have on
yeah so that's the good yeah in my
opinion that is because
the reflection stuff is like nice but
it's like oh look it looks shiny but
like it tanks to performance and at the
end of the day it's it's like not worth
it puddles look shinier puddles look
shinier i think the ray trace lighting
genuinely i just think makes the overall
game look better yeah yeah yeah
and it's worth having i think actually
what i'm thinking of it it does fake
dlss
fake deals
yeah some games will have some games
will have a version of it yeah yeah
i turned the ray tracing off on
um
i only left the the uh environmental
stuff globally yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
your stuff look good okay you got the
good you got the good one but also like
it's i turned some other stuff off
because it was like felt unnecessary
especially when i'm streaming from the
same pc i was like
oh yeah that would probably sound much
but it felt good and like
it's also one of the loudest games i've
ever played like the amount of times
that you went into a rumor is like his
20 minutes of techno happening while
you're just like walking around it's
incredibly loud
yeah i was like this is overwhelming but
it was kind of fun and um
yeah i played like an hour and a half of
it uh because i went in through
like um
the first area where you rescued that
woman
um street kid named desire
um
so i picked uh that i i created a cool
character i also like i i was doing the
character crate and i forgot that when
you like pick
anything like oh oh it just immediately
just straight up like i was like
i'm gonna pick her eyelash or mouth
mouth shape and it like moves the cat
instead of just moving to her mouth it's
like zooms out and it's like fully nude
lady there i was like oh [ __ ]
the best one of those was andy cortez
moving his little face
to be over the junk of the character
that he made
um but yeah so like i picked a lady
called lady with purple hair um and
street kid and started doing that stuff
and yeah i played through the first area
where it's like you rescue the
the high-value target woman in the
bathtub but i played that a couple of
times just because i wanted to see get
grips for how the stealth works which is
fine like stealth's not amazing it's
okay it gets cooler when you have
hacking abilities but even when you do
get a lot of hacking stuff it doesn't
really turn into stealth it turns more
into i'm gonna sit outside this place
i'm just gonna stack everything which is
cool but it's it's not the splinter cell
sort of yeah so like i guess i'm trying
to figure out like do i care enough to
try and do like a no kill run through
and is it beneficial to do that or
should i just like really yeah i think
i'm just going to start because the
shooting feels good the stealth is okay
so i don't think i'm just going to
engage with you
i just ended up going with the shooting
and i think that's the way to get yeah
because it just feels better and yeah
yeah better you can technically i think
get like tranq ammo mods but you're
still just shooting people and they drop
dead and they don't get back up so yeah
the knife skill tree should just get
into knives that was nice yeah maybe i
will do that
sword i'm curious what you think of the
story because i've been told i need to
play all the side quests the side quests
are the best part they are they're very
easily is there this story it's like
ladies like i've i've lost my futuristic
pan can you find it for me
there might be something equivalent to
that but not exactly a futuristic pan
okay um
because the story
has some really cool moments and i think
some cool characters but it doesn't
quite land as well as the witcher 3 that
ending is fizzled out real hard there's
also a secret ending which is a pain in
the ass to get uh
if you don't know what you're going for
so
if you're interested in doing it better
than the other end it's cooler
i think i think so it like and it makes
more sense to the story if you've done
side quests i think you have to do most
of side quests anyway to get it but if
you're interested and you don't want to
know spoilers hit me up and i will let
you know what you have to do
um i actually didn't finish that one
because uh i got to the final mission
and it's very hard um
but it
story wise and characterized i think it
makes more sense yeah send me those
details i'll do that
it
the witcher 3 story is i think it's so
much better it's so much more
interesting and so much more intricate
than cyberpunk
managed to pull off which is agreed a
little disappointing
i i am enjoying it but like i keep
having this voice in my my head just
being like
story's not great though it doesn't pay
off everything you've heard is like the
ends kind of not great and i'm like do i
really want to think i don't know what
50 hours into a game that i know he's
not going to pay off in an interesting
way
i'm with jake though that it's like it's
worth doing the individual side missions
because there are some really good
well-written side missions
some of the endings
some of the ending endings i guess kind
of pose like interesting
cyberpunk sci-fi questions that are kind
of cool to deliberate but
so
still my problem is kind of with the
endings is that it basically
because you can pick multiple endings
and you're essentially deciding which
characters get a conclusion to their
story and which characters don't so it
feels like no matter which ending you
pick you're left unsatisfied because
like watch it just like real life and
these characters get like a conclusion
to their arcs then these characters just
get completely abandoned and it feels
like yeah what happened with that that
all just fizzled out and so like it just
none of it felt
cohesive in a way i don't know i would
have rather the game rather than having
the game
make me pick the story i would have
rather the game which gave a story which
is what the witcher did based on what i
picked yeah which is what the witcher
did
there wasn't
at least i don't think there was a big
choice at the end of the witcher 3. it
was already taken to account the
previous choices you made and these
characters showed up depending on those
choices you made and it fed into one
grand ending well like you're saying
this is very much hey so you help these
people what do you want to do about it
and it's like ah
i thought we got past this creed says we
stuck around knowing about starchild in
me3 you can handle
that's true i you know i i'm not as
like caught up on the ending of mass
effect 3 yeah like i i was
when that controversy happened i was
like i don't really get it like yeah
yeah i mean like
this everything leading up to that
moment was amazing exactly like saying
goodbye to everyone was the bit where it
ended for me and then everything after
that was like you got a call like back
and forth with the elusive man and then
that's it
um but i have like weird i'm very
excited to play more cyberpunk
um which is kind of a surprise to me um
so
yeah i'm gonna stick with it for a
little while longer at least um and if
the if it builds up momentum through the
side quests then i'll play through to
the end was it like 50 hours no
i would say i think it took me
yeah i think it took me like 40 or so
but i did a lot of side stuff i made
sure to do all the main characters i
think
100 of it and it took me like 70. yeah
okay how does it beat cyberpunk 2077 how
long to beat.com is about time who knows
how long to beat.com can we buy that no
ign owns it oh [ __ ] ign
main story 23 hours main and extras uh
59 and a half completionist hundred
three all styles 63. i'm going to start
a website called how long to complete
and we'll see who's
here do it
then we'll see you'll all see and you'll
all see and then then sell it to red
ventures and then you can cash out you
know leave that's how business works
that's how does this work easy i
technically if i came up with that idea
as an employee of red veggies they auto
own yeah
so
um
but yeah uh i'm excited to play more of
that game that's basically what i've
been playing along with uh called the
lamb which can't say anything about
um i keep starting to get into
live alive live live whatever you want
to call it but stopping live a live love
yeah
but stopping like after a little bit i
need to just sit sit down and spend some
sing some time into it
um yeah beyond that
that's pretty much it yeah that's pretty
much it
um let's go on to the topic of the show
which we came up with mere moments
before we hit live
um live alive live alive
based on a dumb tweet i did which was a
picture of joe biden
looking at a tv with bloodborne on it
and looking very happy
um
we decided to come up with
some video games that we what do we
settle upon do we want to recommend
these video games
i was thinking like if if you
recommend videos if you are meet this
person and you have the opportunity to
present them a video game again the
comparison is your matpat giving the
pope a copy of undertale except
you know we'll pick the we're not going
to give them undertale this is this is
you in
game me and game giving uh
jonathan ross batman arkham asylum and
changing his life forever yeah
all right i've got a list here from
yougov america which i didn't know you
have had in america i didn't know you
had an american website um which is the
20 most famous people
in q2 2022 okay
at number 20. i'm kind of just curious
who's on this list
97 fame
what does that mean 73 popularity
rising
elton john oh
okay what video game are you giving
elton john sing star
that's too easy
sings
[Music]
i'd give him sing style
he likes fighting on saturday
yeah mm-hmm uh he's he's a tiny dancer
he knows about tiny dances rocket man
dark void rocket man
yellow brick roads
candles in the wind um
i think maybe like kerbal space program
he can actually be a rocket man
john is ellen john figuring out kerbal
space program because most like gamers
can't figure out yeah space program
maybe like kirby oh kirby's are good
oh yeah
kirby
elton ring i was going to make a curvy
joke about that
ring
ring yeah that's very good that's it
that's it
um oh wait someone says uh creed says no
man's sky
i reckon because he's the el he's the
rocket yeah i reckon he would get on
with no man's sky like you just zone out
for a bit and play
flying through space flying for his
friends
dark void says yeah that's what i said i
would love if he like wrote a song about
his experience playing no man's sky yeah
shall we go with no man's sky for elton
sure let's go no man's sky okay okay uh
97 popularity 97 fame
uh 41 popularity you're not allowed to
look at this oh i okay i can't read it
anyway but number 19
hillary clinton oh god
what are you giving hillary clinton
a microsoft outlook
um
papers please yeah i was going to say
i was going to say some sort of
management
yeah
[Laughter]
what game is about like protecting
information from deus ex
deus ex
for some reason every time i open my
notes app it defaults to the notes for
jojo episode
that's because that's the only notes you
have i've deleted that note many times
and somehow it just reappears oh yeah it
just appeared again
something appeared again i don't know
okay elton john
no man's sky
i spoke with john wrong
no
no man's sky yep
uh hillary clinton
what did we just say did we say papers
please papers please oh damn
we can we can finalize this list later
sex which one human revolution are the
original all right original okay yeah
come on cool okay
all right
next okay with 55 percent popularity and
97 fame
oh you switched them around there yeah
yeah uh these are paul i think
politicians are going to have low
popularity i think what this is like
famous versus popular is like famous
versus like in yeah current like yeah
you know in the in the front of
people's minds but 97
fame 55 popularity number 18
jennifer lopez
oh um
what game are you giving jennifer lopez
don't be fooled by the rocks that she
got
sonic jenny sonic
get the chaos emeralds and rings you
know
affleck yeah
um what could she play
jenny from the books persona 3 dancing
in moonlight
honestly that's not a passion
because she was a dancer before she got
famous yeah the the she was um or gave
her one of the hatsune miku ones wasn't
she selena in that movie about selena's
life yeah
chess at radio
let's give her that
madden 23 she was in the super bowl with
shakira
um she's not enjoying that experience
these challenges
are great i think that's a good one
dancing one it's like a weird unique way
yeah yeah yeah that's a good one
with 97 popularity no 97 fame and 79
popularity is
at number 17
sandra bullock
okay well um
speed so really in 2022 like yeah
remember the bird box challenge
need for speed uh spartan chris need for
speed bullock is she playing me for
speed
yeah
yeah i need for speed let's give no
crazy taxi oh what's that one game um a
desert bus where you just have to play
it forever there's a bus
i've never heard of that game uh it's a
game where you just drive straight you
just you drive a bus straight the
steering wheel
yeah and then the steering wheel
slightly pulse you have to pay attention
to it it goes on for pen and tele did it
right yes it's a pen until it's yeah
it's a pen and teller game and sometimes
it'll be like that you can't just leave
it because sometimes the the will will
pull right on the left and i think stuff
will come is there like a pebble on the
ground yeah it goes for like i want to
say like six or eight hours you get to
the final stop and then they just make
you turn around and go back
and that's the whole game
uh maybe i'll do a stream with that one
day
uh i think uh there's a bus but the vr
there was a there was a group that used
to like for a charity every year they
would they would stream desert bus yeah
sorry i'll just go distracting picture
of jennifer lopez um
97 fame
percent popularity i think that's just
true
number sixteen lady gaga oh oh
what is lady gaga i feel like what are
you talking about star is born oh yeah
what is now what is she
what is she playing though i feel like
she never yeah i feel like doesn't she
already like bayonetta am i crazy i
think she does yeah she might already
have a copy well then i'll just get her
a copy of being out of three women
that's an easy one she does like
bayonetta she's going to be in the joker
sequel yeah she is
oh yeah
i'm weirdly
is going to be sad
i'm weirdly excited about that because
it's going to be a [ __ ] musical yes
it
because
you tell me like i enjoyed that first
movie enough i was like it's fine movie
but i would not need a sequel to it like
a straight sequel no yeah but you tell
me like it's a musical and we got lady
gaga in it like i am now a thousand
times more interested in this you see
cool
you sequel uh
okay yeah in 2018 still playing
bayonetta in the middle of chapter 13
and my hands hurt and i have to sleep
and it's four in the damn morning but
it's
this damn dragon with the face i have to
kill with myself she is a gamer yeah
yeah she's a good guy that is a good
choice i think i kind of i don't know i
feel like she'd be into final fantasy
i could see that yeah
14. get her really addicted to 14. yeah
should we switch it to final fantasy for
you yeah i mean if she's already playing
bayonetta she'll probably already
already know maybe devil may cry oh yeah
she'll be like oh give her metal gear
rising
that's a good one but i think i feel
like devil may cry will vibe way more
probably dudes doing like weird [ __ ]
let's say devil makes satanic sweeney
raises a good point that she was in
american horror story is a big vampire
lady so she could be in uh wrestling
isn't even resident evil i'm gonna say
devil may cry
three oh man if they
she would play make a great uh lady
demotresses oh she would i'd be into
that don't make cry three democrat four
oh if you're gonna pick one you pick
three yeah three almost got a lady in it
yeah
97 fame and 84 popularity at number 15
morgan freeman
well what is the game where you play
guard the sims or simsie oh yeah i was
gonna say spore black and white or black
and white yeah yeah black and white any
any game where you play the sims let's
go the sims yeah
let's go the same so it was an easy one
do you think the sims is grand enough
though
i would watch
a live stream of morgan freeman like
narrating what his sims are doing yeah
he's playing it the whole time and yeah
here's bella goth
he's thinking about [ __ ] his sister
i have installed the incest mod
[ __ ] you ea
you tried and failed
when i'm morgan freeman
and incest is in my video game what did
moobot just delete
pre-incest patchell
[Laughter]
sorry about mumbai with 97 fame
and 52 popularity at number 14
madonna
this list feels like it was 15 years ago
you know
there's no doji cat on there like what
are we doing yeah i might switch up this
list you know
i mean i i
yeah i mean i don't know i think maybe
we stick with it at this point unless
you can yeah yeah we
it's still good enough
when they're [ __ ] mentioning like
charlie demilio's or whatever yeah
no i found a list that could be but i
looked ahead and the list is not very
interesting going okay okay well
madonna degenerate is on here
oh god
oh insult generator insult uh what's
that game we just insult everyone oh
yeah
um
i'm switching this list up because i
can't think of anything for madonna
what's a game that has you plagiarizing
art
that was one of the weirdest things i've
ever seen
what could
should we carry on with mcdonald's which
one uh
i mean not plagiarizing but maybe uh
she was the fencer in dine of the day
another day yeah
oh super hot what's the star breeze game
where you rob banks is this give her a
copy of payday give her a copy of payday
i don't know enough about madonna either
though i don't know
which which era
because i don't care about madonna i saw
her live once she was [ __ ] amazing
um i'm just gonna skip my donna we're
gonna go to this new list because it's
better number twenty mark zuckerberg
here we go
again
we're gonna speed up okay speed through
speed through because i got a picture
mark zuckerberg
oh some kind of [ __ ]
it's not one where you're spying on
people spy party no wouldn't it just be
the what's the horror game where you're
looking through cameras and [ __ ] five
nights at freddy's no no no no it's the
space one the one that blew but oh no uh
what are you talking about tacoma tacoma
no it's just
tacoma's not a horror game it would just
be the metaverse he'd play some dumb vr
playstation
no we should give him vr chat because he
keeps talking about the metaverse and
it's like that already exists it's
called vr chat here's a copy go play it
yeah you get it you get it ariana grande
that's sonic seven rings
sonic yeah chaos emerald
sonic
mania okay yeah let's give it a good one
yeah observations kim kardashian
um
bubble bubble
for that bubble bubble
uh which one bubble bobble is that what
you said
[Music]
yeah um
what else can she have
she's got her own she has her own game
kim kardashian's mobile game
uh
and she's bought her own mobile game
yeah
her own mobile game see if she notices
yes you should
rihanna
oh um
what's a game
that hasn't released
a new oh she'd be gta because
no no no i know where you're going you
know where i'm going because everyone is
waiting for [ __ ] gta 6 and gta hasn't
released anything since 2013 and that is
[ __ ] rihanna she's never releasing
any more music what's with this weird
like we're giving it based on some
passive aggressive like do you think you
give a turn she's like is this because i
haven't released an album yeah
the moment i saw rihanna i was like i
bet you should love beyond good and evil
i don't know why but i was just like
she's she gives me a beyonce that's a
good game yeah yeah i mean sure i would
give that to someone be like here you go
umbrella core
risk of rain
power simulator umbrella court was very
good so what are we giving her
umbrella call
don't want to give her a bad game oh uh
i kind of like beyond good evil because
they just felt genuine yeah definitely
like i don't know
i feel like she would be like oh i like
this character jade's nice
uncle paige
and the next celebrity is jlo so we
already oh what was jlo again um
space channel five oh yeah after that
we've got selena gomez
um
i don't know much about herself she was
in wizards of waverly place so game we
do magic
oh
oh the sims uh has a magic expansion
maybe we should have done just what
celebrity should get sims expansions
because
yeah i would [ __ ] kill that
rapid fire those uh the sims making
magic which is for the sims one
it was the final expansion pack for the
scene
win three room three win three
oh lego harry potter is another good one
what would oprah winfrey do
um
you get a
you know that's what oprah you you get a
prize and you get a prize she's always
giving advice you know what you know you
know what you know when she does that
you get a car in unicorn that reminds me
of the end of peggle when you know you
get the big she would be into okay we'll
give her a penalty
yeah taylor swift
um what is taylor swift playing
elden ring you reckon taylor swift's
playing album i think everyone should
play firstly she's she's redoing all of
her albums right now so i have to be a
remake i think resident evil 2 i was
going to say she's sorry
yeah there you go one who who's uh mr x
scooter braun probably yeah exactly
current affairs i'm gonna skip will
smith we're going to will smith punch
out
i was going to go for what's the other
one
we played those weird blobs that keep
trying to slap each other for each other
out of the gang beast
uh
robert downey jr
anthem
yeah i guess
i don't know
he's playing anthony
his likeness isn't like yours
[ __ ] jeff bezos oh jeff bezos needs
to play that uh flash game about
his money or whatever yeah
i don't remember what it's called let's
find out what it's called jeff bezos now
can we give jeff bezos um what's that
weird um you are jeff bezos yeah
make him feel bad a little bit oh what's
that weird weird
corporate murder game that came out last
year
hitman
no it might be playing i mean
man forget it yeah
jeff bezos uh give a give him hit man
yes actually hitman's a better answer
than what i was going to come with
can you imagine him that's not just
going to make him have even more of a
power trip because he's looking at a
character that looks just like him well
he gets away yeah i could do it too
that's how we bring him down
or he's like he like implants like uh
you know his rivals his business rivals
as them it's like a fantasy right he's
like i gotta murder them yeah
okay we're going with hitman
adventure capitalist god's playing
what's that adventure capitalist
that's another game that he could play
um but we're going with hitman elon musk
oh god
kerbal space program yeah yeah
so we can test it
is to
make [ __ ] happen
space program he's getting kerbal space
program
maybe it'll get stranded in space
his kerbals
oh
uh joe biden oh bloodborne you already
know
yeah yeah he gets copied
look alive jack
the rock
what kind of gaming no what game has the
most number of like ads in it
fortnight
he's playing fortnite yeah or clash of
clans i don't know why that one came up
but yeah
are we going to fortnite yeah
yeah i think it's foreign
and that is the list so we have elton
john no man's sky hillary clinton day of
sex
jennifer lopez space channel 5 sandra
bullock desert bus lady gaga devil may
cry 3.
morgan freeman the sims mark zuckerberg
vr chat ariana grande sonic mania kim
kardashian her own mobile game
rihanna beyond good and evil selena
gomez the sims making magic oprah
winfrey peggle taylor swift resident
evil 2 remake will smith punch out
i like how will smith has done just like
albums movies shows and the only thing
he's remembered for now is just
slapping
someone [ __ ] oscars yeah
uh robert downey jr anthem
lebron james multiverses jeff bezos
hitman elon musk kerbal space program
joe biden bloodborne and the rock
fortnight i think that's a pretty solid
list yeah i think we've done our job
today yeah we've done it we've done it
we completed the assignment thoroughly
and that my friends
brings another episode of the gamespot
after dark podcast to a close
um if you would like to send us
questions which we do occasionally read
out questions when there are some you
can go to uh discord if you can't get
into discord you can help me or lucy and
we'll do a background check on you i've
had i've done i did four background
checks this morning
really well on the phone oh while on the
toilet did they all pass they all passed
yeah excellent they all passed yeah hot
rob
is that hot rob handlery
that is his tweet your twitch name is
hot rob i don't know if that is
[Music]
oh my god i don't have it in front of me
i don't know what he said
can it not be repeated no
rob behave yourself
this is your platform you could get done
for her
that wouldn't reflect on us badly that
reflect
you mad man
um
get out here
we love europe this is good okay bye
okay
if you would like to send us yeah yeah
so you can uh contact me or lucy and
we'll get you an invite into the slack
if you pass our rigorous slack slack
right into our breaking news
congratulations here's a news story
[Music]
uh you can find me at charlottesville if
you
so desire and uh i'm
playing games
[Laughter]
jake
i put out a pretty in-depth uh xenoblade
combat guide so if you're playing
xenoblade and you want
a little extra help i'd check that out
uh there's something else i'm working on
i'm going to talk about it later because
i'm still writing it it could be out it
could be a very long time from now
lucy
i am uh these james games everywhere
look out for some sandman stuff from me
on the site tomorrow it's gonna be a
written thing not a video but i've been
working on that
i am tomorrh everywhere and i ain't
working on anything so i don't do any
work
uh we're shooting online show tomorrow
are you talking about oh that's gonna be
a good one um i think anyway
i read it it was good
and we will see you
if you don't wait before we go if you're
here and you haven't already hit follow
make sure you hit follow because if we
don't get enough followers we will
abandon this
it's news to us is that is that right
yeah in five star ratings on five star
ratings only yeah yeah yeah yeah we we
can only get you to follow and like and
subscribe by threatening to take away
the content
you sound like my mom
we will we will take the love away from
you and you will learn
okay
um it worked one person hug already said
i did it so the system works
you get to you get to wake up another
day yeah you get you get it you get
another episode of this podcast
hopefully um and if you're listening on
podcast services make sure to um review
the podcast so it gets shoved into an
algorithm somewhere and gives us a
better chance of doing more of this
stuff anyways
shoves gets gobbled up by the algorithm
yeah gobble gobble gobble gobble uh
we'll see you on the next week on the
next on the next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you